[Music]
when we talk about networking in AWS
essentially we talk about how you can
isolate your resources in the cloud
that's something that is a key concern
or key requirement for all the
organizations that are moving their
workload to the cloud how do I do that
and you can do it using VPC the virtual
private cloud we'll take a look at
virtual private cloud as well then you
have something called elastic load
balancing where you can say I have many
applications and I want you to do a load
balancing for those applications and AWS
gives you out of the box functionality
managed service called ELB elastic load
balancing which will do just that
AWS also has something called route 53
this is a fully managed highly available
cloud DNS service and what it does is it
basically acts like a phone directory so
you put your IP address and put your
website address and it converts that to
the IP address and then brings you to
your source which could be the s3 bucket
or your load balance or really anything
[Music]
let's go to console and then take a look
at this thing right now I am in ec2 and
then I am at the load balancers if I
click on the load balancer I can have
two types of load balancer where I have
an application load balancer so think
about this if I am a retail website and
I have something like apparel I have
sports outdoors all of these sections
and I have a social section as well on
my website and I want load for all these
sections to be managed separately and
then what I can do I can come over here
and I can set up some target groups and
then I can distribute my load for all
these sections of my website so
essentially I want to change the load of
my traffic and I want to divert that
traffic and I can do that all from here
and this again is available for HTTP and
HTTPS if you want to do a load balance
again a network land like a TCP or SSL
then I'm going to choose the classic
load balancer VPC or virtual private
cloud again is a place where you can
isolate your resources in cloud this is
one of the places where you can use a
VPN connection to create an encrypted
epic tunnel to talk between your data
center and your resources and clouds so
your VPC can talk to your resources in
your data center and you can do that by
using a customer gateway at your end
your data center end then use a virtual
private gateway at your cloud end there
are firewalls that you can set up which
are called network access control lists
you have subnets which is a logical
grouping of your resources so you would
have resources who would talk to the
internet you would put that in your
public subnet by using Internet gateway
attached to that or you can have subnets
that would not be talking to the
Internet but will be talking internally
instead
hey what's become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here